[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je retrouve la force de l'équipe qui
m'avaient accompagné en 2008 ceux qui
sont à mes côtés ne sont pas des
politiques et ne veulent surtout pas
l'être ils ne cherchent pas être député
dans deux ans secrétaire d'état dans
cette conseillère départementale l'année
prochaine et aiment leur ville et
veulent tout simplement s'investir à
cause de cela ils n'ont pas d'ambition
personnelle
au delà de la réussite de leur mandat et
de celle de la commune de la force de ma
liste également c'est également mon
expérience de douze années de gestion à
la tête de la ville de vie d'épreuves le
point phare de mon programme est de
savoir justement de quoi je parle un
programme ne doit pas être eu une suite
de propositions toutes plus belles les
unes que les autres un programme ça doit
expliquer d'où on vient où on souhaite
aller pourquoi et comment on le fera
toutes les initiatives de notre
programme sont construites de la même
façon elle se base sur l'histoire de
villepreux sur les projets déjà mené sur
ses perspectives mais également en
prenant en compte les difficultés
budgétaires déjà présentes et celle que
nous allons vivre dans les prochains
mois nous avons bien conscience que
notre programme par rapport à d'autres
fait peut-être moins db et on sait très
bien que le rêve à être toujours été au
coeur de nombreux de mes discours mais
la période qui s'ouvre devant nous
nécessitent très clairement de mettre
comme priorité la réalité
[Applaudissements]
dès mon arrivée je gèlerait l'ensemble
des projets majeurs d'investissement et
en parallèle à l'instar de ce que vous
connaissez le côté ski au niveau de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous créerons le codho vie de comités de
développement de villepreux il sera
composé des forces vives de la commune
et aura une responsabilité extrêmement
important celles de définir la feuille
de route pour les prochaines années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]